[Music]
welcome back so in the last few lectures
I've introduced the fast Fourier
transform which is a computationally
efficient way of taking the Fourier
transform of data and in the next couple
of videos I'm going to show you how to
actually do this in MATLAB and in Python
and for the first example I want to cook
up I'm basically just going to show you
how to compute the FFT of a signal that
is the sum of two sine waves so kind of
a two-tone signal we're going to compute
its its Fourier transform using the FFT
and then I'm gonna show you how you can
use this to denoise your signal okay
good so the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna walk you through this
code and this is the MATLAB version you
can download all of this a databook UW
comm so the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm gonna create a signal in time
from time 0 to time 1 with a delta T of
0.001 and I'm gonna make my clean signal
be the sum of two sine waves sine of 2
pi times 50 times T plus sine of 2 pi
times 120 times T so these are 2
pure-tone sine waves at 50 Hertz and at
120 Hertz and I'm adding those up to
make my clean signal then I'm going to
add some noise actually a relatively
large amount of noise so this clean
signal is gonna have amplitude kind of
plus or minus 2 and I'm adding noise
which is a little bit bigger than the
size of the signal okay so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
just run this bit here and you're going
to see kind of I'm going to plot the
true signal and the noisy signal okay so
here we have kind of this is this is
time on the x-axis and then this is the
signal and the white signal is the clean
two tone data you can tell that this is
kind of just two frequencies interacting
with each other over time but red is my
noisy data that I've added Gaussian
white noise to okay and so we're gonna
play a game we're going to pretend that
all we got someone you know sent us some
data we had collaborators and they sent
us this red data
here and that's all we saw is this red
data could you tell that underneath all
of this noise there was actually this
this kind of white signal going on okay
that's the game we're gonna play okay
good
so now what we're gonna do is in the
next section here we're going to compute
the fast Fourier transform we're going
to compute the Fourier transform with
the FFT command and in every language
the FFT is basically a one-liner so all
of the guts of the FFT algorithm are
built into this one line command FFT and
so you tell the FFT command what your
data is this this vector of data F and
how long that data is how many elements
in in the in the data vector n okay
and so in one line I compute the FFT
this is called my f hat okay and now
what we're gonna do is remember that all
of our so we went from F through the FFT
to f hat okay and this is a vector of
Fourier coefficients each of these is a
complex valued entry okay so each entry
of this Fourier transform vector these
are vectors of data and this is a vector
of Fourier coefficients and each element
of this vector of Fourier coefficients
is a complex number it has a magnitude
and a phase okay the magnitude tells you
how important that frequency is how much
of that particular frequency sine and
cosine are in the data and the phase
tells you if it's more cosine or more
sine and we're in between okay so here
the the power spectral density the PSD
what I'm doing basically is taking F hat
times its complex conjugate divided by N
and what that really means if I take
some complex value lambda times lambda
bar that's another way of just saying
what is the kind of magnitude of lambda
squared okay you can work this out if if
lambda was a plus IB then lambda times
lambda transpose lambda transpose or a
complex conjugate is a minus IB if
multiply those I get a squared plus B
squared my minus I squared becomes a
plus and so lambda lambda transpose is
just a way of doing this on my whole
vector of data to compute the norm that
the magnitude squared of every single
one of one of these entries okay and
depending on what your input data is
depending on what F is this might have
units of power and that's why it's
called the the power spectral density
okay so you can think about you know if
this is some signal in time then your
Fourier transform will be frequencies
which have units of per per time and you
can work out that this PSD has the right
units of power okay and so the last
thing I have to do is create this
frequency vector so this is just in
MATLAB you have to figure out like each
element corresponds to a specific
frequency from low frequency to high
frequency and so you have to figure out
what your fundamental your vector of
frequencies are here so it's 1 divided
by DT times n times a vector from zero
to n so from lowest frequencies zero to
highest frequency n okay okay good and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
plot that power spectral density versus
those frequencies here and remember
we're computing this on our noisy data
so let's run that now okay so on the
noisy data that someone emailed me this
red data I compute the power spectral
density so this now has axis of
frequency this is in units of Hertz
okay so 50 Hertz 120 Hertz in fact you
can actually see right here kind of the
50 Hertz spike and 120 Hertz spike in
the data I really should be labeling my
axes so you at home please label your
axes and this y axis here is the power
in each of those frequencies in the red
data so this is called the power
spectral density plot and it shows you
which frequencies in units of Hertz have
the most power
and so right off the bat you can see
that when you compute even though that
red signal looked super noisy and messy
when you compute its power spectrum when
you Fourier transform the data and look
at the power spectrum of those Fourier
coefficients you can see quite clearly
that there are two very large Peaks and
then a bunch of noise kind of a noise
floor and so this gives you some idea of
how you might filter your data so what
I'm gonna do is I'm actually going to
just draw a threshold at around a
hundred and anything that's larger than
100 we're going to keep and anything
that's smaller than 100 we're going to
manually zero out that's gonna be our
noise filter okay and so that's what
we're gonna do here so we're going to
use the power spectral density to filter
out noise and again in MATLAB this is
super simple what I do is I just take I
find all of the indices of the
frequencies where the power isn't
greater than 100 so this is an indices
it's a vector of zeros and ones it's one
every for every frequency where the
power spectrum is bigger than 100 and
it's zero if it's less then I take my
power spectrum and I multiply it by
those indices so anything that was in
the noise floor gets multiplied by zero
and only the values that had a power
greater than 100 get multiplied by one
so it only keeps those big peaks and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
plot those and I'm going to inverse
Fourier transform and plot the clean
filtered signal so once I have let's
let's write this out then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to filter basically
the power of F hat squared less than a
hundred so anything that has power less
than 100 I'm gonna kill it so then I'm
gonna have some you know F hat filt and
then the last step I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna run an inverse fast Fourier
transform to get F filtered to get my
original signal but filtered okay so
we've computed the FFT now what we've
done is we have zeroed out all of the
entries with small Fourier coefficients
and now I'm going to inverse Fourier
transform to get my clean signal in time
and when we do that this is what we get
okay so remember we drew our line here
and so anything that had value less than
100 we just killed it and so you can see
these kind of light blue filtered spikes
here these are after filtering out the
power spectrum okay so I've killed
everything smaller I'm zeroed out those
coefficients and then when you inverse
Fourier transform this light blue signal
what you recover is a very very clean
version of your noisy noisy data so even
if someone sent you this red data and
didn't tell you that there was this
underlying signal this white signal that
was low dimensional and clean you could
Fourier transform your red data you
could see that you had two strong Peaks
zero out everything small and then when
you inverse Fourier transform you
recover your clean signal so this is
super super useful for for cleaning and
denoising for taking data that might be
from real experiments real noisy data
and pulling out the dominant frequency
components and cleaning out everything
else and in this example we kind of just
walked through how you compute the
Fourier transform and the inverse
Fourier transform how you interpret the
power spectrum so it's literally how
much power is in each of these
frequencies in Hertz so we had a sine at
50 Hertz and 120 Hertz and you see those
pop out clear as day and then you can
filter an inverse Fourier transform to
get a clean signal okay so pretty
powerful this is really kind of just a
toy example but you can see right away
that you could probably use this in lots
and lots of applications okay thank you